I feel like the system is just trying to
shut doors in my face and trying to
create this invisible wall so yes I have
faced certain hindrances which is
because of the fact that I choose to
work honestly but I think it is worth it
right so my dream has been to create a
model village bring about a holistic
development in this village and then
help other villages
my name is javi rajawat and I am an
elected representative I had a village
council in Rajasthan and the council the
village is called sold out that's what
my family hails from
so it was a reserved seat for a woman
also with reference to caste and
religion right at the very beginning I
made it very clear that I'm not someone
who believes in dividing the society
that I do not I will not work on caste
pieces so the basic amenities such as
good education electricity water
employment opportunities ecological
balance that there's no no one working
that sector as for rural sector is
concerned my village would by and large
represent many other villages
you
so the issues were really really crave
forget water for irrigation we didn't
even have water for human consumption
there's a high percentage of Down
syndrome because people are consuming
contaminated water in a village
everything is interconnected so for
example if I didn't provide for a safe
source of drinking water what good would
a good education institution do
obviously he or she will not benefit
from that
so my secretary because he's been part
of the system he's you must be in his
early 60s so he thinks that unless and
until you don't bribe or do not get
bribe things won't happen
but I keep telling him that while he's
used to that I'm going to prove to him
that one can still work in spite of it
to provide safe drinking water we had to
harvest as much rainwater as we possibly
could unfortunately the government did
not have any project or any scheme that
could have funded our initial project
that is where one needs to reach out to
the private sector and flat for days i
was able to collect 20 lakhs of rupees
we brought in the earthmovers the
machinery and we were able to in 24 days
d silt 10 acres of the hundred acres and
i think we were just lucky because after
long spell in trout spell 2010 so quit
once UNS and i think within the first
shower itself a reservoir that 10 acres
that we excavated had been filled
so what that did was it also changed the
mindset of the villages because what I
wanted was for them to participate in
any development projects that we brought
into the village
it's been nearly five years and there
hasn't been a single moment when the
system has not tried to break me but
instead of getting disheartened I
actually get more motivated by it
you